alle kräfte bietet man die kommt halt
dein maul
das kann jetzt echt scheiße jetzt liegt
das alles geil
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
wie dropper 2 zusammen mit max egger
kran crafter wo bist du da bist du und
zwar zum zum ersten mal mit der
nachricht deutlich grad bekommen
nein zuerst mal mit dieser webcam wo ich
gerade drauf zeige und zwar mit der
neuen die ich mir gekauft haben alle
offen livestream die funktioniert jetzt
die webcam und deswegen hoffe ich mal
schreibt mir meine kommentare die
qualität findet und sonst ist alles gut
bei uns ich habe auch im neuen licht und
ich habe auch neue filter drin und zwar
packte ihn jetzt nach dem premieren also
jetzt gerade sich die nicht aber so ein
paar colour collection sachen und es ist
sind nur noch ein paar level wir sind
jetzt gerade nämlich hierbei level 15
und zwar hardware macht das letzte mal
schon mal oder so was habe ich denn
jakob geschwindigkeits boost max
verbleib so 15 schon längst drin
ok ich fahr runter acht medaillen
letzten lanciert als bibel spät berlin
geladen aber wahrscheinlich weil ich es
gab wieder ab in dem es wissen ich renn
da gerade nebenbei und ich glaub mir
after effects neue version runter und
ich sehe alles total spät format damit
einverstanden es wird eventuell jetzt
der letzte part sein ich bin mir aber
nicht sicher
so jetzt jetzt ist die welt geladen
nein ich sehe die sache niebel spät
ich weiß nicht auf daran liegt das ist
bei mir anders und viel service
sag mal sehen wo stellen wasser vom
firma überhaupt an kopf bei uns eine wie
weil beide 7 diamanten wenn ich also
noch zwei level aber wir brauchen auch
etwas geht nicht um diamanten es geht am
fels und deutlich mehr geht nicht
diamanten ich dir helfen investieren
sodawasser luca auslacht herausbringen
das wasser direkt neben dem wasser
gelandet wo springst du lang alltäglich
einfach nicht verstehen wie schaffst es
denn da andere auf der anderen seite her
zu springen muss immer irgendwo auf der
anderen seite her springt also ich werde
eventuell die webcam sogar da oben da
drauf packen
also eventuell nochmal wissen vorstellen
könnt ihr auch in die comments schreiben
so schadet man ja auf dem blog starten
glaube ich ehrlich ja wir kommen viel zu
sagen wir besser
nein auf den schwarzwald in diesen
blöden fertig würde ich will immer
direkt davor oder bist du definitiv egal
woher hast du bitte ein feuerzeug
ich habe ja kein feuer vielleicht hast
du gar nicht mehr direkt auf den pfeil
als alle kontrakte
ein feuerzeug wollte alle kraft
entschied dass man die kommentare halt
dein maul
das kann jetzt echt scheiße hin jetzt
liegt das alte luft ich möchte sagen bei
dir läuft ganz dezent ich bin kein game
mode schreiben fertig repariert
liebesleben er warum setzten land eg hat
jetzt ein bau ja ich bin jetzt auch ja
geil der schalter ist übrigens auch bild
und die welt einer direktschaltung ist
auch kaputt glaube ich habe gerade /
knopf küche hin als sagt knopf bitte
müssen wir noch weiter bauen max sollten
die sonst kommst du doch wieder irgendwo
anders
deren elterngeld
ja wir können ja nicht sterben nein
kommt setzt das hd game mode dem würde
wenn ihr findet das so fraktion unnötig
findet niemand hier halt macht voll spaß
gemacht der luca sehr genau der lupe
er liebte lukas gemacht hat
so wie ich max kenne
geht der kilt er sich jetzt aber nicht
so bleibt der verbunden
ich weiß nie welche richte ich muss
irgendwie um die dings umspringen
eigentlich vom blassen genau auf das ist
echt heftig das ist ja ich hab einfach
immer am anfang schon 0 als auf einmal
sitzt direkt los
solch eine andere technik gibt es da so
gegen diese linie so viel milch ein
wo ich glaube das ist gut ich glaube das
ist gut fördert irgendeinem flugbörse
angefühlt ich liege wasser alte junge so
was bei mir am anfang immer ein nein das
ist knapp aber ich habe jetzt eine
taktik wo ich mich in stelle entdeckt
da bist du witzig max bist du witzigmann
ich verrecke nur nein
wo muss ich den nachruf liegen stellt
mit hier inhalte
ich lieg schon wieder am wasser alter
ist kann doch nicht sein dass es so
knapp ist
ich hätte hier hin eigentlich dürfen ja
nicht aus diesem gebäude hier austreten
wir dürfen nicht über die schneeflächen
rausgehen sage ich noch nicht luca
bietet lukas lukas geschafft nein aber
ich weiß die taktik ich weiß nicht
umstellen muss
entstehen wird es auch einfach hin
vielleicht ist vielleicht auch gut
afag drück wachs zurück nein du bist
draußen
wieder halt dein maul verlust gehen
hätte wie schaffst du es an dem finger
vorbei scheiße a schon wieder im wasser
gestorben
so und jetzt ja direktor mich also passt
ja im wasser geil so ja wie bist du
jetzt bin ich echt so wachs muss jetzt
neben leuten
hier warten wieder bissig sprungkraft
auf
jüngst hat jetzt dem minister ist nehmen
da weiß ich doch und ich bin jetzt
gerade da
ich hab den diamanten
okay ich bin ich runter bringen sogar am
ach scheiße junge alma war geil und zwar
witzig so blauth knopf wieder zurück in
die lobby erwarten auf mich alter es so
warten zumindest vorne
okay ich hab so viel scheiß einmal das
ist abnormal scheiße doch das ist keine
kennen kennen mich sondern sperma oder
oder was meinst du aber auch wo der
diamond wenn die an der jazz ich habe
acht und zu mir ist ein verrottetes
fleisch und diamanten bleibt alle kran
kräfte in die kommentare
und konkret schreibt alles beide zweimal
ich will nachher 3000 kommentare sehen
unter drei millionen
was ist da wie moria 0
neulich auch panik es muss man milch
trinken
warum ist das so dunkel scheiße alter
ich wenig beachteter der dings gibt
einem nachtsicht ich hab milch getrunken
deswegen meinen 80 weg weg weg nie
wieder recht bitte bitte noch die nie
mehr sorgen um geld mit einer hand bitte
bitte bitte
sorry ich treffe das a doch jetzt hab
ich was das denn
energie soll weiter knopf versteht davon
stellt überhaupt alte kommen wie ethisch
dass aus dieser drache oder was das ist
walker dreh dich mal um ruft bei dem
drachen muss ich eigentlich machen wir
ganz kurz gamer 30 spielstationen bist
du merkst du das ist echt ethisch
station übernehmen
schreibt kongo absage entschied halt den
schnupfen
das war somit das dümmste was in meinem
leben gemacht habe ich war in der luft
habe ein gamer weggenommen musste normal
machen auf das scheiße da man weißt du
wie ein weg gefunden hat
jung ist es blöd ich kann ja nicht dass
ich war noch drin
ich war schon wieder drin
muss ja doch bestimmt wie hoch so ich
bin gleich beim diamanten
ja ich habe jemanden hier unten in
seinem erdloch den drachen die hochachse
wie du musst entlang des pfeils da
laufen und dann immer weiter oder wie ja
genau dann kommt person turm oder so was
ähnliches und da musste um die ecke
laufen aber ich hab den diamanten wenn
ich habe ich zu wenig gefreut yaman ich
habe jemanden okay ich lauf weiter hast
du auch den schalter ich noch weiter
hast du den schalter jetzt auch hier
unten weil ich doch einfach die ganze
zeit
ich finde es einfach nicht und ich
glaube einfach jahre
zum drachen was zum drachen alter dem
pfeil entlanglaufen bin ich einfach der
explosion nach jetzt
ja gesehen nach hin doch ich sehe dich
alter bis zu weit weg da wo ich bin ich
bin rechts und nicht links rumgelaufen
hier da musste kommen
ich sehe dich
das resort ist vor
haben hier entlang kommen erst
vorbereitet
cool habe ich aber nicht gesehen weil
einschätzung genug wo da wo ich dann
gesprungen sich aus die grand canyon
oder so und dann hier unten in die
spinnennetze ja wo bist du denn lange
sprung bank ist über hindu springst
irgendwas um meister warum siehst du das
nicht hier wo bist du denn da unten wo
soll ich denn da runter kommen dann
einfach springen hier unten ist ein netz
ich kann noch mal hoch ich hab's
trotzdem überlegt ob ich okay hier
drüben war weil die kiste egal ob man
also hast du jetzt auch acht ja okay und
wo ist der schalter der schwarzl der
blaue noch keine ahnung ob ich irgendwas
explodiert hier ist bei dir auch so
dunkel nebels in einem anlauf
gescheitert hier wenden 88 sicht
wir werden jetzt einmal stirbst hast du
die nicht mehr da bist genauso am arsch
wie ich gesagt dass ich sterbe ich nicht
mehr schaden sprungkraft 0 scheiße jetzt
verklagt den sprung muss jetzt schaffen
wie komme ich denn jetzt wieder hoch wie
binde ich bin gegen den rücken hals
gesprungen
schon wieder hat es geschafft als ab
junge ich jetzt einfach mal den weg hier
weiteren coup da irgendwo der blaue
schalte ist mit gone bad wenn hier
neulich ist eine fackel sadd sports
konrad hier oben gesetzt natürlich hab
ich auch schon bei uns nicht geben oder
in der eventuell wartet die baskets bonn
da war noch mal so ein ding ist noch mal
so einen pumpkin eventuell muss man hier
wieder runter bringe der banken war der
weg nicht ist ein zweiter dabei werde
ich jetzt endlich kann ich mal ein
becken oder so dass ich rein springen
muss ich dir nur einen schwarzen scheiße
junge fakt ist dass niebels dunkel wo
ich stehen knopf ich könnte mir einfach
einfach töten wenn wir auch oben
hier wird auf einmal hell
wie crazy naja egal ich würde sagen die
nächsten part sehen wir bei max weiler
weise zehn minuten sind und deswegen ssl
geil
erstes trotzdem dunkel wenn es euch
gefallen hat dürfte gerne einen daumen
hoch da lassen das wird uns definitiv
freuen
nächster part ist dann morgen bei kran
kraft auf dem kanal der kanal nach oben
in der beschreibung genau drauf gehen
abonnieren
und dann wir uns demnächst wieder